[Music]
how nice you guys are [ __ ] sweet did
my mother call in advance or something
treat him nice tonight because it's a
[ __ ] anniversary of sorts ladies and
gentlemen it is Saturday night and Reno
Nevada
so let's babble the [ __ ] on for the
100th time man I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph
Garman thank you for being here tonight
Reno as Kevin mentioned is our 100th
episode of Hollywood babble-on little
did we know a couple years ago we'd be
doing this for a hundred [ __ ] times I
know there are very few things I've ever
done for a hundred times it's
masturbation and this it's a it's a
milestone man it's and it's been a
delight to sit beside you for all this
time you make me laugh it's I get to
listen to those impressions over and
over again has been a blast and look it
brought us to Marino together biggest
little town in the world right here it's
what this is what does that mean exactly
biggest little city in the world I
haven't figured what a Skrull was
scrotums biggest scrotums well now that
I'm in town has the biggest scrotum yes
[Applause]
they are huge so you've heard and the
legend I've heard man I remember it was
passed down from generation to
generation sure my grandfather sang it
to me when I was a boy it's like big
balls big balls they called him the man
with big balls
gar man was the man with big old there
is a second verse even more meaningful
oh how dare you sir
well you're witnessing the final episode
of Hollywood babble-on this evening
let's get to it you know it is our 100th
episode that we're celebrating tonight
and just well-wishes galore from
everyone who listens thanks so much for
all the emails and the tweets also
celebrities have been contacting us
letting us know how happy they are to
celebrate our 100th episode when he says
Leopards you mean like Jason Mewes yeah
professor Stephen Hawking [ __ ] that
really smartest man in the world
he sent a little audio message to me
today at least I think it was him so I
brought it along to play for everyone
and here's professor Stephen Hawking
congratulating Kevin and myself on our
100th episode was that it he included a
score he's the smartest man in the world
course he's gonna produce it what an
arrogant prick
he knows how time works and [ __ ] cut him
a break it's actually not a bad idea to
carry your own score around man
see so when you're saying [ __ ] you're
just like I really mean it you could
play like [ __ ] Batman music or when
you're into the wife and you're like I
want to give you a back rub it could be
1:06 you but just but no lyrics just the
bullying of the musical version
good evening Ralph and Taven I have been
enjoying your podcasts after long days
of solving the secrets of the universe I
wanted to make sure you have a shout out
from me on your 100th podcast
congratulations although I have a good
sense of humor I have to say your
impression of me performing creepy clown
sucks a bank of hairy balls I could do
better even if my caretakers built my
feeling tube with a fifth of Jack but in
all seriousness thank you both for all
the funny keep up the good work
and give that penis a sandwich oh here
we go really recognize any brought back
bring to give that penises ham with only
appropriate
[Music]
you
[Music]